ding-ding-ding-ding-ding think I can
follow away from me - welcome back to
the Jenna Julian Pompeii it's been a
minute it's been a minute we took a week
off we did we took a week off we took
with VidCon big opportunity so we didn't
see you guys last week so we missed you
finally back how do you then it's not
right now so good good to know
Jenna's wearing a jumpsuit that we got
is the army surplus store oh yeah yeah I
also have this in camel and it's like a
really great outfit just in case you
ever looking for affordable clothing it
is very fun and exciting go to your
local army navy surplus supply store Oh
Julian has taken it upon himself to pull
out his ghillie suit wait I have a
question for you though Julian I love
you so much where we just clean out that
closet why was that ghillie suit just
smashed in the corner right there Julian
Julian I don't like I'm not here okay I
don't know if you can see me but you
can't see me
can I explain why I was in there yeah
okay
because no it wasn't just in there it
was smashed and white in the door and I
couldn't see it would put Neely to the
side and honestly I don't know what
you're talking about can't see it it's a
ghillie - it's invisible I could I wear
more the whole thing layer what is this
something I said when I said why don't
you explain to them why you have a
ghillie suit I had just given suit
because I play a game called player on
those battlegrounds and then in the game
you can get to me from an airdrop called
ghillie suit which is basically a
camouflage suit so you can blend into
the grass and I found I took to it so
that it was like my favorite part of the
game and so naturally when we're at the
army surplus store I got a ghillie suit
a full-size ghillie suit so he has a
Panhandle shirts everything yeah I can't
even see like anything okay he's done
playing on Twitter
like that in the ghillies he hasn't
twitch.tv uh Sharon Julian you know
Gilly actually that was going to
transition this episode of Genesis in
podcast brought to you by lift right now
guys you can get a $500 new driver bonus
when you sign up to be a driver for
let's go to lift ly ft.com slash
annejulien and get started limited time
only terms apply lists treats their
drivers right and they are the dopest
ride-sharing service out there check
them out naturebox also sponsoring this
ya guys if you want to eat better and
you don't want to feel bad about what
you're eating and you want to eat
delicious snacks that are constantly
changing and being introduced go to
naturebox.com/tyler angeline and you get
three free snacks with your first order
right now right now the only thing about
this case is you can't eat and you have
to you have to get it get up in there
can I contrast because on is okay well
you can do whatever you want but for
sure I feel like you're mad about the
apartment eight I'm mad okay I'm not no
because this room was sort of a mess and
we just spent all this time cleaning it
and clearing it out and then we do the
same thing with the office I'm like
Julian Alec I'll do it with you because
there's one a couple times on all
cleaning a room without you and then
surprise you and then you're like yeah
it looks so great and then it just goes
back to like Julian throws who's counter
paper towels but it's like that but with
all of Julian's belongings or whatever
like we clean this room and you've
already just shoved something into the
corner of Madison for you la where would
you have liked it to go because just let
me preface this yeah you and I were both
eating snacks and a lot of your snacks
were left on the computer table of the
we just cleaned and I cleaned all of it
up so where would you prefer that to go
but snacks is like I left that hearing
that I'm going to throw it out it I had
a choice between putting into fondant
whistle l-system that's all I'm asking
for just a little system alright Verna I
love you I would be too I'm sorry you're
a really great dad I'm also sorry that I
was taking a little longer to get ready
for this podcast because I was listening
to fill the franco interview casey nice
set which was lit I'm only like halfway
there is that more
Podcast take an hour right yeah it's
really nice all the way that they're
speaking to each other with a level of
respect you don't often find on the
Internet yeah it took what an actual
conversation between adult human being
sounds like it's really great the holy
[ __ ] like Phil does an incredible job
interviewing him but you know like when
you're interviewing someone the dynamic
is just here's the question here's the
answer back and forth a little bit like
do somebody [ __ ] pack needed because
I wanted three-way debate real bad take
me in tankmen I was [ __ ] I'm here
just sitting like arguing with that
phone we need to have Phil in the pod
cam yeah I between you two him a long
time ago we just you know we have this
really great system on a podcast of like
we book our own guests you and I
together so it's sometimes it's like so
either you can come over tomorrow or no
I'm actually in the process of sort of
upgrading this our home studio right now
like it's not going to be any crazy but
we are in the process of changing things
and once it's all done it's going to be
a lot easier to be like hey person of
the internet please come into our home
yeah because more and I mean it's clean
now so it was nice but before I mean
this is this was kind of a pit of
despair that I would not really like the
head well it's like it's like the kind
of podcasts or like we feel comfortable
inviting our friends and like moms over
to but like anybody beyond that it's
like I'm it's sort of too embarrassing
to be like hey you want to come BMG odd
cast if you have to be all right just
step over these four lights try not to
trip over this cord you don't see in
this room it's where Julian throws the
dart it's like our gaming rooms our
podcast room yeah we do it all in here
smells like shut up so today we are
going to do something that V Fox did
before us it's not like most requested
there's someone to the top comment on
the last podcast it was we eat together
have to answer the top 100 most googled
questions so I printed out a list of the
top 100 most googled questions on the
same list that was used on the Vsauce
video I think that was like a big thing
that people watch yes Michael here and
it has the search volume with each
question as well so that's interesting
I like comb through this list
and on the ones that I can't really I
can't [ __ ] read anything right now on
the ones that require oh hey hey done so
professional podcast why is your nose
wet the dog so at the top of his nose
see the dog like it's one specific spot
oh maybe he sneezed and I got up on his
face he's on your face on the questions
that involve math and kind of conversion
stuff I look those up so get off to sit
here and he drifts on the pizza coupon
jiffy Wow goodbye anyway why don't we
spend how do we start so I guess the
plan is wool
we'll both trust try to answer them as
best we can yeah and then if we don't
know I'm really a girl it's ID and Peter
come here oh look at look at our
professional podcast wow this is a great
podcast podcast and pop pop for those
you that are listening right now we have
two Italian Greyhounds on the table oh
and they're looking each other alright
alright question number one not ready
ready for this I don't think I'm going
to do well what is my IP like how am I
supposed to know that so you know what
that question is I get I P address yeah
you know you to answer because every
source not searching it is there our
number right so people searching for
their own IP on Google basically or are
they searching for what an IP is now
that they're searching for their own
eyes are on up to you yeah all right
okay well we can you answer that three
point three five million global search
volume and so I don't actually know what
the time frame of that number is but
whatever what time is that so number one
no number one most searched question on
Yukon Google like why why are people
searching for their own IQ so much I
don't know I what I want to know is why
okay it's a lot of licking guys you
don't want me like it all the way off
the table I know you don't be in the
dilly how are you comfortable how in the
world are really sharp limbs just on a
table laying down anyway I find it weird
that like ite addresses
are that difficult to find to wear that
many people have to Google what theirs
are right like you can't just like
search in your computer like where's
Maya P or IP or go to settings it's like
it's that difficult to find that that
many people are dealing what their own
IP is yes by the way if you Google what
is my people that tell you I don't know
I'm afraid to Google I don't want to
google it like I'm just thinking for my
own personal life I've never needed to
know what my IP address was never not
one single time why does anybody need to
know house so what though we set up a
VPN for the twitch stream right but then
that gives you a different gives you a
master right but you didn't Google for
five minutes before that what your
current but you didn't need to know what
your IP well actually I know how to find
your IP you go on the speedtest website
where you check your internet speed is
your IP but that's totally different
than the other linearity but I'm just
saying like I've needed to know what it
was once one cat once
and that's only because we do [ __ ] on
the internet for the average everyday
person who doesn't work on the internet
out why they would need milk maybe
they're just scared they think they're
getting hacked I'm sure there's a very
logical explanation for this please let
us know in the comments because we
cannot think of it right now
I can't what's the matter you don't want
to like you you just don't love you
tomorrow next one what time is it
absolutely the bit okay you can answer
that how other people might have a
[ __ ] watch an iPhone a clock you're
googling what time you're using a device
when that device also tell you what time
it is yeah oh my god I'm so loud Curtis
you have to stop you there but okay I
love you but we're recording how to
register to vote that's number three
that seems reasonable that makes me
happy that that's yeah that's actually a
little more encouraging all right
usually on the ground
I'm so sorry Kimmy okay come on
but anytime that there's like a
something like that where I find myself
googling like how to like a full
sentence of how to do something I kind
of feel dumb but at the same time I'm
like you know what [ __ ] it like I don't
know how to do this I'm going to enter
it in Internet machine and I'm going to
get an answer
get valuable information when when you
google something like that it'll
probably tell me like a nice state yeah
and also we'll take you to a nice
curated like infographic article where
it shows you exactly how to do I I see
nothing wrong with that one yeah
how to tie a tie I know how to tie a tie
I only know how to tie it one hang them
all right I only know how to tie it one
way the Windsor
yeah is that where you lived it over
twice a double Windsor I know how to do
that one yeah I never thought I'd - it's
that except the way I learned how to tie
a tie in college I learned how to tie a
tie in college because I wore a tie like
all the time because I was doing on
camera like reporting stuff but the way
I learned how to tie it wasn't the way
that I that I still tie it like I
basically developed a new way to tie it
that isn't proper but like when you tie
wins or not and you and you're done and
you pull it it like pops out and it with
mine you have to untie it because I like
the way that tie looks better
hmm it's like a little bit tighter a
little bit more clean obviously I'm like
not you know minority in this one but
yeah I'm definitely not a connoisseur Oh
ties definitely not okay ready yeah
number five can you run it what can you
run it I don't what does that mean I
don't know what do you think they were
trying to say uh-huh can you run it I
think maybe as an accident honestly how
many times 550,000 can you run it
alright next what song is this stop wait
so they think that when I listen to a
song and they type what song is this
their brainwaves are going to translate
the audio into the search stop what song
is this that's the whole job it's like
you're trying to like DIY Schism stop
follows that my favorite are you ever
seen um like on yon [ __ ] answers in
[ __ ] where it's like what song is this
and it's like just the literal spelling
of like doo doo doo doo doo dah dah dah
dah dah
and people try to get yeah that's what
that google searching idea like come on
that's rough what song is this Wow okay
how to lose weight 3 and above
reasonable eat better exercise that's a
little like basic layman's answer but
whatever that's a fair question number
seven 550,000 yeah how many ounces in a
cup I want to know if you know those
eight eight ounces in a cup yeah I don't
know I'm gonna go a 16 okay I'm gonna
check the answer key on the back number
eight not a nothing but eight eight
ounces here yeah well don't say no thank
you
ah when is Mother's Day [ __ ] a go is
it different every year I don't know I
searched Mother's Day is May 13th 2018
yeah that's what I'm saying so it might
be different every year which that makes
that reason about makes that a question
reasonable yeah I don't know when it was
this year but it was May cuz it was just
it's in May and I know Father's Day is
in June but I don't know exactly she
definitely think it does twitch every
year how many ounces in a pound take
since I was 16 I think will be checked
yeah 16 how many ounces in a gallon is
it 64
he has 128 in the sink cut it join it I
own is 128 in ounces
I was halfway there how many weeks in a
year 52 52 when is Father's Day June
something that's funny that people keep
googling things that they don't want to
get in trouble in our fathers June 17th
2018 so next time is going to be June
17th the Internet is fun and everything
y'all I just gotta make sure my mom's
not mad at me okay there's another there
repeats also what is my IP address no
this one says address but first I didn't
say address then the next question is
can
I run it not can you run it what is
running it what what are they talking
about okay that's amazing to me I'm
using HIV every [ __ ] from that
question because I don't know what it
means I don't know what it means what
does that mean can I run it what is that
like a an unfinished like the absolutely
started before there yeah what I thought
like some of these questions I feel like
might be the most popular beginning you
know I mean hmm mmm interesting
interesting okay like if you're asking
about a program can I run it on on a PC
to any means yeah still a really big
stupid question wait am i rounded what
the [ __ ] okay I'm running on the next
one is number 15 how to get pregnant how
to get pregnant know how to get pregnant
oh okay number sixteen thousand
correctly yeah but it just reminded me
of a yeah purgin an organ ant 368 how to
get pregnant people really go about
three hundred sixty eight thousand
people do though that according to this
website well in the context of like a
mother that's like trying trying to get
pregnant I understand in like a pea
risotto that's a website yeah and just a
purely philosophical way but not like
what is the biology of how people are
pregnant I noted yeah I think it's more
like people wanting to get pregnant I
don't know that's an area that seems
pretty dumb Quinn just like a lot of 11
year olds maybe I have a light smoker I
don't know are we done yeah
how to download YouTube videos that's a
funny one I understand of understandable
there's a lot of ways to download
YouTube you they trying to rip them in
[ __ ] well and also like there's
obviously good ways to be downloading
content to use but there's a lot of very
bad ways true to how to screenshot on
Mac oh my favorite like shift alt for
whatever no channel awesome playoff for
the and watch the screen so yes I use
that all the time because when I would
write the blog back in the day I had use
all the time to make swords
yeah it's a really helpful tool how old
is Donald Trump Stephanie one [ __ ] how
did you know that right - yes I looked
her up I don't know I'm just judging by
how tight his watch was on his wrist so
he knows like sure yeah funny it's why
I'm so tight it's so why is it so tight
watches it's alright it was just these
pictures of him golfing and he's wearing
this little gold band and it's just it
looks so unbelievably uncomfortably
touch he just gives me okay
how to lose weight fast boom don't you
feel bad don't eat food don't drink
water oh don't no one listened to Julian
oh just honey yeah it's essentially just
died yeah there's like starve yourself
till you're lighter and then wither away
but that's so awful yeah I mean there's
so many unhealthy ways to lose weight
like that are on the internet but a
really really healthy way to lose weight
is by going to nature box you guys can
get healthy snacks that are guilt-free
you know and they taste great and
there's up to a hundred different snacks
that you can choose from made from
high-quality simple ingredients which
means no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners what I say
IRRI [ __ ] guys we all want to eat better
but when it comes to snacks sometimes it
feels like the world is delicious and a
billion calories versus boring and
tasteless and it doesn't have to be that
way you can up your snack game right now
with nature box my favorites are the
strawberry lemon-aid fruit stars and the
Santa Fe corn sticks and the sea salt
cassava chips those are delicious but
they're like not trash food okay if you
don't feel bad about it you'll
definitely find your new snack obsession
with nature box they add new snacks
every month inspired by real customer
feedback the latest food trends and
professional chefs it's so easy go to
naturebox.com/tyler my feet choose the
snacks you wanna know deliver them right
for your door for no risk if you ever
try snack you don't like don't eat it
nature box will price replaceable free
right now nature box giving the ding
damn three free snacks with your first
order of the nature box.com slash Jenna
Julianne that's nature box
calm / annejulien three free snacks with
your first order also right now lift is
looking for new drivers and lyft knows
that their drivers are what keep them
moving so they do everything they can to
make sure that drivers are happy on
every trip it's a simple formula happy
drivers have a mean happy passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lists
ride to get a perfect five-star rating
you can earn hundreds of dollars per
week plus tips one or more money drive
more it's that simple you can turn on
driver mode wherever you are whenever
you are and and work a little bit this
was the first ride sharing platform of
tipping Bilbray she's tickling my feet
so right in via because getting tips
shouldn't depend on a customer or a
passenger having a crumpled bill in
their pocket and you keep 100% of the
tips and seriously they add up fast live
drivers have been paid over two hundred
million dollars since the feature was
first introduced also you can get paid
almost instantly with no waiting for
weekly I paid live to taking the
guesswork out of pickups as well which
the new amp device uses color coding to
find your passengers which is really
really helpful right now join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to ly
ft.com slash annejulien
get a $500 new driver bonus and you're
working you get a job
all right let's calm flash annejulien
limited time zone 85 all right all right
sorry you know what I'm savoring your
foot it remind me of that documentary
tickled or whatever oh my god that
[ __ ] documentary is a wild it's the
weirdest competitive tickling we've ever
talked about that heavy no I don't think
so but I would love to do something on
the podcast where you try and do
something and you're getting tickled at
the same time can you do it this is
right right now pop sign answer these
questions all you tickle me okay but the
best way to tickle me is to like sit on
my chest that sounds weird okay what
makes you laugh I can't stop laughing
she's like I'm not like super debulking
Alysha but like if you say I just like
it's just about can't read you want
engineers oh no they don't write here
we'll wait for you Helena you're the one
who brought this up okay this is all
your fault
Jesus what is happening all right come
here but you really have you have to do
like a lovely I will pull my weight on
air
I'm dead nice super hum eyes on that
don't hurt me no absolutely no don't be
gentle
- I guess today Julian Charlie chose
just to go breathe it was really good
that doesn't mean we're so happened when
somebody likes set down your chest is
that you you want to try to throw my
chest to see if I laughs do it to me
when we're not related
no time this probably looks really
really really really really really good
mm-hmm always like straight blue what
where were you see how okay you see I'm
not going to do it you're saying I know
it's just like you sat on my boob
that's your check though yeah yeah okay
well I want to be done with this okay
yeah I just reminded me this mm-hmm I'm
check all right pray for Jenna one like
equals one prayer
it's not like it does oh yeah does it
not for anybody else I don't know I
don't really try sending it but actually
time I've also never tested it my best
time like in middle school and high
school or whatever that Batman is
full-sized laughs I like Heights we
would just take turns like sitting on
each other's check it like feels really
funny is that weird it's just no it's
not weird cuz I don't I don't know if
that would make me laugh it does try it
what we on I don't know okay here where
are you now wait where they know where
are you now
oh maybe it's the Justin Bieber song go
get them imitating song okay yeah so
maybe that's what it is how to make
pancakes go wish it mi want pancakes
how do you make pancakes off top your
head flour oil water butter
can you fry them and make them a little
bit vanilla
ya know if you have like some binding
like a banana or apple sanya hainan is
great for baking again consider bags
yeah love you Simon is when we were
young like what
when when we were young we were around
it wasn't that song what song that's
when you were you yeah when mother
killers yeah the killer song that we
heard that in fries yesterday and I said
to Julian that's the only song that I
can play on expert on guitar hero we're
doing any different times I ain't know
you do that with your eyes so does do it
my heart no one is so sketchy and weird
thank you you pretend like you're gonna
make eye contact is so busy well the
initial plan is to make eye contact
pinatas and I board mission I'm not
making eye contact when I know it's
going to do it
no not looking at you it's like the
weirdest sensation feeling like
someone's going to make eye contact to
do they just lightly miss you on purpose
yes calculate mama follow me trap it
does it feel weird yeah it's like
waiting for a sneeze or something it
never happens okay all right we're at
number 24 we're going so slow may I make
it through all of them because most of
them are cities we need to speed that if
you want to because how did it make
money
mmm fair question not maybe the best
route of going about finding it out too
big it's way too big of a question yeah
you got it you got to figure out
something else and make money I mean
there are definitely will hanging fruit
I wonder what them don't mean you in the
meaning of life how do I fall in love
how do I find somebody like if you
figure out how to make money isn't that
like figuring out at least a quarter of
your life yeah but it's arguably not a
sustainable way to do it it's a finger
on a sustainable amount of money to
support yourself in correlation with
your lifestyle like it's so not a click
google shirt so why is this number 24
well how many grams in an ounce
oh no that 16 two grams in an ounce I'm
gonna take 32 grams I know I'll [ __ ]
only five twenty eight point three five
for everybody
time for grams a lot of our audience
uses grams babe is sensitive I don't
have time for gram I know I was only
Teddy when we were just hanging I was a
buddy Matt chose from Australia and as
friend Jake they came to visit he was
like we were talking he'll ask me like
distances and how much things and they
don't understood
I just like to understand if they
understand miles and kindness and
kilometer yeah he was like how far you
from another like two miles like I don't
even know you just said I'd like no
kilometers made a like me 1.5 hours over
how many feet in a mile 312 whoa
300 if you're saying if you hit a home
run run oh I don't know a mile I know
that you have an ATC am i oh hey I just
thought of a rnases song up in my head
right now
no it's I know that those notes have
never been funny
I know it's not from rent 525,600 it's
5,280 feet of my yeah I mean what's up
are you sure nothing come on first like
it was just let's just think about what
three hundred twelve feet in a mile
wouldn't I just like spit something out
sorry is really funny 312 feet if you
run across one football field you then
run a mile Harriet if you return a
touchdown you ran a mile through it a
mile here the if you if you put three
hundred get it with foot to foot that
would be a mild kisser what time is it
in California only on the N I'm guilty
of this so I always do that I'm like I
asked Siri but I have serious stuff but
I guess is it does this count as serious
and junk this is Google search with
Google search but why don't you just go
on to your like app for linklok I'm
going to play devil's advocate if you're
at the computer and you're at the Google
search bar and your phone's over there
maybe just time today
I tied i tighted the dumb shits Google
and I know I'm dumb doing it but I don't
know okay I asked Amazon and I asked
what you're saying no I asked
a very dumb [ __ ] what does sm h mean
like someone just anchored a friend to
all sales I mean no so these are all
Perry all moms all parents what does sm
h mean man shaking my head shake in my
head
call the hillary clinton hmm I'm gonna
say she is 69
yeah wait what do you mean yow did you
get both very oh no you did I looked it
up she's 69 yeah Nia but the fire that I
was making it gel she's 69 and he's 71
and I don't know how I knew that all
right we are now doing a speed round
we're at 29 let's go to 40 speed round
right yeah how was belly fat diet and
exercise
how is it going to rain today probably
not where is my phone this itself unnie
of Google speaking here I have no
[ __ ] clue where you planning on so
you put a check around me hey that we've
been so [ __ ] perfect uh hey where's
my phone okay what is weather today
looks [ __ ] outside no but also like I
don't if you find yourself googling like
what is the weather outside though just
get yourself a weather app or something
for your computer you can get apps for
your computer
I mean I'll understand what is like the
weather going to be like what is the
weather now I don't know but like
there's more why don't we just do that
then at Google at every single day how
to download videos from YouTube already
answered how to boil eggs you just boil
them you just met him in [ __ ] on a
lot how do you boil anything you throw
it in a pot boiling water just boil a
giant pot of oil and then throw the eggs
in with the shell on colleague elite
Instagram account see what happens when
you do that
I probably deep fries
perfectiy final an egg hull with a show
on what happens I don't know I imagine
it would cook it in a pretty weird way
and how to delete Instagram account how
to take a look at do you answer that you
just delete it okay
how to take a screenshot on that card
yet sir how many cups in a gallon 8 no I
don't know 13 how many cups in a gown 1
gallon equals 16 cups
how many date till Christmas go on it's
July so many and that Alverno vendors
way around 150 a few years how many days
till Christmas
it's 176 named Joseph care what time is
in London again enough okay six out
ahead hold on we are fine another 12
hours ahead are they yeah Oh cuz you're
in California yes over 20 area
well ours ahead I think it's 4:20 in the
more masking take 3 what time is it in
London England Twitter with nine hours
ahead Webster Poletown sink Hey it's 8
hours ahead a tarp and from LA where am
i oh my god 165 thousand searches stop
stop it for all those people just like
lost in the woods for like several years
they don't even Google what year it is
they could both tumble tonight I am boa
how to get rid of bed bugs Oh brutal I'm
not going to follow anybody for looking
that up because bed bugs are awful [ __ ]
that yeah week three of them we're all
right keep going
how to draw a rose okay you know this is
the dude who like didn't get to the
flower store on time on Valentine's eggs
like [ __ ] I got to drop something dope
how do I [ __ ] make a rose on paper
- I agree excited how to make a pizza
oh you can do it oh poor poor Google
Sarkar you can figure I don't you can
make a pizza out of anything like
starchy tomato and cheesy you can make a
pizza in a mug in two minutes okay and
really how many grams in a pound God
beer it's done
I don't know who cares - who cares how
many ounces in the court dumb how to
have sex how to have sex op it how to
have sex
stop I wanna have it stop how to say
we're gonna do this anymore
tap-in one perfect around what comes up
a video an infographic or step by step
step by step it's right in tutorial
Michael Jordan mean stops out pop them -
stop it
how do you spell is not how do you stop
as not how do you spell I don't know I
thought how do you spell no I think that
that's like an incomplete women and the
word has come comes after that how do
you spell and then consciousness
no I spell I don't in the con comment
below right how'd you stop that makes
sense people are trying to stall word
yeah that's like the first why are they
search that because these are these
numbers have been searched I think
whatever see but I don't understand why
you would bother even typing in how do
you spell and then you're hacked version
of whatever the word is just start
typing in the word that you want to know
how to spell it way to spot that's why
you're literally like that's so smart
the the like your level ahead of the
people who are searching it's like these
people are literally going there touch
me and is calm entering in the search
box I get searching in the Google thing
how old am i what
[ __ ] am i oh god I hit okay how do you
snapchat ask your kid that's fine no I
think that's fine can I have no problem
with that
alright fun I have a problem ever like
genuine enquiries I feel that you're
fine some of the stupid ones are just
stupid
alright speed round versions ones I also
understand I just don't feel like
answering them should I grow we're at 50
we're going to 60 okay what is your name
stop that's a name that's a question
what is your name
No what is your name maybe they're
trying to talk to the computer get to
gnome do that weird I thought the eye
thing at me how to make French does what
a friend is better friends the kind of
friends go to France and he toast that's
so funny that the oh my god peach she
okay oh she just picked the mirror I
thought something's like caving in alone
so if we had pancakes french toast and
pizza delicious yeah good good good
taste okay me ground how to make love
how to do it in 30 seconds or less how
to say how the divet sex and love how to
make slime get out do the interchange
get out with your slime to this shame
I'm triggered how many tablespoons in a
cup how many tablespoons got 54 it's 16
tablespoons in a cup what is the time
wait what time is the Super Bowl that's
understandable yeah how many except for
the fact that it's literally advertised
everywhere yeah but so how many ounces
in a cup I'm not enough of these what
time is sunset don't even laugh you ask
Siri that all the time I do that one's
fine all version ones are fine too
they're just annoying day what time is
sunset is the most fair question I don't
know why I'm laughing I'm just got the
giggles how to write a check okay that's
funny
well just like that oh my god okay how
to tie a bow tie you buy one the target
I'm gonna nollie we both actually looked
up here we go
how to tie a tie how to tie a tie are
probably the most yeah once I've done -
when is daylight savings time make sense
how many days in the year 365 you want
to know something embarrassing yeah I
was looking at the answer key for these
I literally start selling because I was
like wait how many days are near 366 it
is a leap year what does a chub you mean
Millennials hit me up yeah how many days
until Christmas here yes I want how to
make money online people how to make
money online I feel like that's valid
but again way too vague of an of a
question more turn is an Australian if
you want a real answer you got to narrow
down your question what are they
expecting I don't know like an article
to just like solve all their problems
that's one step one how to have sex
step one how to make a love find a
person find another one of one that
looks like you what time is it in
Australia just ask Rome when is right in
your hand where you been all of us make
sense to me yeah those change May 28
2010 perforce that is next year okay
what is the temperature fair but you
know if they would just download
themselves a weather app then they could
look it up on there and they wouldn't
have to google it every single day how
to solve a Rubik's Cube that's been fun
Oh week what's wrong with that okay fine
that's right how many countries in the
world do you know that one but hi 1961 I
think it's 206
oh [ __ ] is it really yeah damn it he
sings this song I can only hope that
they're like typing out to Dada Dada
Dada there's a good clean how many
tablespoons of teachers and tips and how
long to Braille eggs really no I don't
know thank you reckon
why is the sky blue
because of the sunlight passing didn't
have to do with the wavelength or P
atmosphere and how we perceive color
alright whatever those yeah can't how to
write a cover letter okay you know what
we were in the middle of recording a
podcast that one yeah damn you all piece
of paper at the cover step to start
writing on this when I district what
that reminded me of his I've done in
Sponge Bob Ernie has to write that long
paper and he like works for hours and
hours it just has the really fancy th e
like the in that we know how to do the
fancy Old English sorry agenda and watch
Spongebob she's too careful I'm too old
how much house what how much house can I
afford how much house and honey what is
the time stop why people keep asking
what is the time I'm a gain weight
finally someone asking the real
questions here gotta take a screenshot
vague how to hack a Facebook account
ah no question here number 84 most asked
how to hack facebook at all jealous
boyfriend and girlfriend and then the
next one is how to delete facebook
account it's like almost like skin color
alright how many megabytes and gigabytes
playing at 10:24 there's no ideas okay
so this one I searched how tall is Kevin
Hart okay and you want to know when it
gave me five six six foot four that's
funny that's [ __ ] lot hey Siri how
tall is Kevin Park age let me check that
Kevin Hart I just six feet for consumers
in 30 pounds on what world is this paper
in somebody know it that's somebody
Wikipedia yet somebody ended mister
peeny page she's eating your ghillie
suit by the way you you don't need the
ghillie suit yet not that's my ghillie
suit so she I literally looked over
there she had a full mouth of ghillie
and was like pulling it off of here
while we were playing games of the day
she was on the kitchen table eating our
ramen she was eating broccoli
specifically she wasn't eating anything
other than a little bowl of broccoli
Colin Kotter how to start a business
fair fair question but that's so big how
to start a business in two words
who will go [ __ ] off um how old is
Justin Bieber 23 people I'd taste like
28
he's between 23 and 24 how many people
are in the world seven billion hey Siri
how many people are in the world let me
check on that checking on that 7.28
billion so basically however many of use
of Justin Bieber video has that so many
people are trailing [ __ ] how to last
longer in bed
so we're progressing here okay
it's how to have sex and then it's how
to make love and then out of the
advanced peeps out there how to last
longer in bed and they're not just
saying insects they lean on the lingo
it's in bed sweaty guys really how to
make money fast okay that is ridiculous
faster what is wrong with classes of
that how to make it fast for one this is
like how to get famous now
how to draw a Doge - duck para dog
that's really nice I like that what
about just like googling a [ __ ]
picture I'm enjoying it I don't know but
that sorry that was rude I'm sorry
enough that's really sweet to each his
own I was just trying to draw a dog -
how to get rid of acne fair enough fair
enough we've all googled that how many
ounces in a gallon come on come on no
bad to get 128 ounces they're all can
try to get rid of blackheads just call
Jenna and she'll get them out I won't
get much Josie's how to cook quinoa
is a pretty daunting food to learn how
to cook it's weird well learning curve I
mean I used to do all the time too and
if you're going to eat it by itself you
toast it first and then you do is that
yeah those recipes are confusing when I
even came on in like late high school
early college when I first started like
learned how to actually cook for myself
and the biggest thing with quinoa is
like in a different like conversely to
normal pasta or rice or whatever
actually similar to rice but conversely
to normal pasta you don't drain it at
the end the water soaks into the food
and then it just dawn which is kind of
confusing at first but what's the
meaning of life
question number 99 that's a great
question I don't know why I think that
they're going to go to it and find it
hey Siri what's the meaning of life
don't catch baby series [ __ ] funny
how many calories in a banana 80 105 on
average there according to Google or
Siri well there you go guys
you must be so much smarter now that we
answer those the do sex how to do sex
better in your head no no no I think of
it those are all backwards how to get
pregnant was the highest and then how to
have sex then how to well better in bed
maybe means like how to like get in bed
without getting something pregnant yeah
teacher how do you get better in the bad
high PG I can't believe she's eating
your dairy food tell me my ghillie suit
come on she a good glial though for you
there's a thousand of these there's like
literally the top thousand question so I
guess we could potentially do more
confirmed even most of the more
conversions which I understand but it's
also like it's not a very exciting with
question number 117 do you want to build
a snowman
hell yeah these are funny though
well shout-out to you guys are giving us
dumb suggestions and I hope you guys
enjoyed us trying to answer the top 100
most googled questions on the podcast
right paid a pretty good now we are
going to go enjoy our 4th of July we
hope you guys have a great fourth of
July as well they're not much
yes in a non-sexual way no you know why
can't I just have someone to
platonically sit on my chest
what's wrong with that what's why why is
everybody got making a sick thing you
guys are sick I'm gonna that's that's my
new Twitter bio what why can't I just
ask someone to put platonically sit on
my chest
Jenna 2k 17 it feels good it's funny I
hate everybody
I understand none of what you're talking
I hate everything love you guys think
think Sam see you guys later
also we're on Twitch a lot so if you
guys care to check out a lottery line
which we were playing a lot July and in
getting same I go to and I also promised
a 24 hour stream so that's going to
happen soon kailia have a great day guys
have the voice alive
[Music]
[Music]